there's one really important nutrient
involved with
hypothyroidism that you need to know
about now this also relates to a
hyperthyroidism too so if you have any
problems with your thyroid this video is
going to be very very important now the
first thing to know is that 90 percent
of all hypothyroid problems is an
autoimmune disease called Hashimoto's in
most cases of hyperthyroidism is also an
autoimmune condition what is an
autoimmune condition it's a situation
where you have
cells made by your own body okay there
are very specific types of
anti-bodies against the body little
cells that actually attack your thyroid
so you have these cells that are
programmed to think that your thyroid is
like a pathogen so these antibodies
attack your thyroid and prevent it from
functioning and they create a constant
inflammatory condition as well and
ninety percent of all hypothyroid cases
are autoimmune now let's talk about this
one nutrient that's really important you
probably thought it would be iodine
it's not items very very important
because without iodine you can't make
thyroid hormones but selenium selenium
is really important and you're going to
understand why in a minute because most
of the selenium in your body is mostly
concentrated in your thyroid if you go
by the weight of that tissue and if you
have a hypothyroid condition chances are
you're probably deficient in selenium
it's very very common to have a
deficiency and when you get diagnosed
with this autoimmune disease okay the
three main antibodies that they find a
problem with involves one that's called
thyroid peroxidase so these antibodies
to thyroid peroxidase really uh inhibits
your ability to make thyroid hormones
because one of the functions of thyroid
peroxidase is the production the
synthesis of thyroid hormones and so you
can just imagine by blocking that you're
not going to make enough thyroid
hormones thus having a lowered amount of
thyroid hormones that's called
hypothyroidism and then there's another
one okay that involves the receptor for
thyroid stimulating hormone that's that
hormone from the pituitary that's sent
down to the blood that connects to the
thyroid and tells the thyroid to make
thyroid hormones and that receptor is
called thyroglobulin receptor so if you
have antibodies against that receptor
you're not able to receive the message
that tells the thyroid to make thyroid
hormones so you can imagine what kind of
problems you're going to have if you
have antibodies to these three parts but
the good news is that selenium can help
significantly reduce these antibodies
and it's something natural that you can
take and it's in your food but you can
take it in small amounts to help you
also selenium improves the thyroid as a
whole okay
so that's another benefit selenium also
helps you convert T4 to T3 T3 is the
active form T4 is not so T4 really
doesn't do much in your body unless it's
converted with the help of selenium I
mean think about this let's say for
example
you don't have enough selenium and
you're taking Synthroid for example
which is T4 synthetic T4
and your problem is you can't convert it
to the active form
you're not going to see much change you
might have normal T4 in your blood but
what about the T3 you really need to
look at that to make sure that is uh
insufficient amounts and so the point is
like where's the real problem is it in
the conversion
is it in the production selenium has
also been known to decrease mixed edema
which is a big problem for hypothyroid
situations it looks like that but it's
not fat it's like the puffiness that is
throughout the body that makes you look
fat but it's not an actual fat now
selenium also decreases inflammation why
because it's involved in making
glutathione one of the most powerful
um antioxidants in the body and this is
why selenium is so important with your
liver as well
and that's a whole different topic but
selenium can help prevent a fatty liver
it can help prevent inflammation in the
liver it can help prevent fibrosis in
your liver it can decrease your liver
enzymes it can even decrease the risk of
liver cancer now selenium is also high
in certain types of fish
and so if you're concerned about getting
Mercury from certain fish a fish also
has selenium which makes this protein
that helps get rid of mercury in cadmium
now mercury has been linked to
autoimmune conditions of your thyroid
and cadmium by itself directly inhibits
the production of thyroid hormones so
here's yet another reason why selenium
is so important for these conditions
selenium even decreased the risk of
getting an autoimmune condition because
apparently when you're low in selenium
there's a higher level of initiation of
autoimmune problems it's kind of like
the match that triggers the fire and
also as a byproduct of
thyroid metabolism you have this
hydrogen peroxide so selenium helps you
make glutathione that helps you deal
with this hydrogen peroxide which is you
can create a toxicity in your thyroid
also when you get Graves disease which
is a hyperthyroid problem a lot of times
you get these bulging eyes well selenium
helps reduce that symptom too now where
do you get selenium well it's in meat
it's in fish it's in eggs it's in Dairy
cruciferous vegetables like cabbage and
broccoli it's in nuts it's in onions
it's in garlic and it's definitely an
organ Meats selenium can also help
decrease
the risk of getting those thyroid
nodules and it can even help prevent the
enlargement of your thyroid and your
thyroid has other mechanisms of
accumulating selenium helping recycling
it and making sure that you're not
ending up in a low selenium situation I
hope you now know the importance of
selenium as it relates to the thyroid as
far as doses go of selenium of course I
would always recommend eating foods high
in selenium but I would recommend the
200 micrograms of selenium each day in a
nice base of other trace minerals just
to make sure you're not you know
creating an imbalance and if it is true
that you have these antibodies you have
this autoimmune condition whether it's
Graves
or Hashimoto's I also recommend another
product I don't sell it I'm not
affiliated with the company that does
but it's called thytrophin PMG it's from
a product developed by Standard Process
okay so you can look that up you would
take one before bed and that works a
little bit differently but I think the
combination of both of these would be
very very important in helping you
recover and for more information about
that I included that in this video right
here you should check it out